music the mystery of music what needs
recalled so rightly the mysterium
tremendum the mysterium tremendum of the
last act of wisdom and many other cases
many other cases it can be an attitude
of Chopin it can be a phrase almost in
Mozart speaks to us that there is
something else which paradoxically
belongs to us profoundly but somehow
touches on a universal meaning and
possibility that we are not only an
electrochemical and neuro physiological
assemblage that there is more in
consciousness than electronic wiring
music seems to me more than literature
the great force the hope of a
transcendent possibility that is why tis
so vitally important that our children
be given access at the earliest time to
good music I sound like a boring old
reactionary I don't apologize nothing
frightens me more than the withdrawal of
serious music from the lives of millions
of young children the replacement of
many forms of music by the horror of
organized Noize by the barbarism of
organized Noize the deafening folly of
not letting a child encounter good music
of not teaching it an instrument if
possible of not teaching it to sing if
possible there was a time in daily life
in nineteenth and early twentieth
century Europe when an amateur
performance was a natural attainment of
educated people it needn't be very
good need to be very great but it was
part of a coming together and of being
in touch with that mysterium tremendum
of the transcendental if they take that
away from us we are indeed in very deep
trouble but I don't think they will be
able to during the worst periods of
despotism in tyranny people could learn
musical scores by heart even where music
was forbidden they could still commit it
to memory music is very difficult to
censor yes it can be stopped it can be
suppressed musicians can be hunted and
hounded and tortured but still it is
there in all ways it's strange mystery
remains the Concertgebouw is a place in
which to remember the last concerts of
that very ambiguous genius furtwängler
the lights went out regularly and we
have recordings where you hear the
gunfire of the Russian artillery
approaching Berlin and Furtwangler
Beethoven and one Hyden recording at
that time played in the dark the people
in the audience knowing they were doomed
knowing they were doomed into a horrible
fate and there are no greater recordings
or readings of that music known to me
than those there's something in the
music which is much stronger even than
our greatest performers the music in a
sense plays us we are played by it that
does not mean that there will be
agreement on its meanings
that does not mean that we will not
continue to debate fiercely about the
choice of a slow movement from a
Bruckner Symphony to mark the death of
the Fuhrer we have a recording and it
too is fantastic it's one of the very
great recordings for many many years I
was trying to understand why music does
not say no at certain occasions at the
how as you know is just outside Munich
just outside and the trains with the
people in them dying of thirst and
hunger on the way to Dachau used to pass
not far at all from the great music hall
in that hall Giza King was giving his de
BC cycle and good judges say that
there's never been a greater
interpretation of Debussy and my
question was to German students and I
began asking it immediately after the
war the German school children why did
the music not say no which is a nonsense
question but is it a nonsense question I
still don't know the answer could the
music have refused to be played of
course it could could it have been
played wrong at least could give a king
he played wrong notes at least didn't so
the mystery remains but so but so does
the strong urgent hope that we will not
let them take away from us that
overwhelming experience that privilege
of being which is great music I thank